(laughter)
You have information.
Information I need to have.
I will not tell you anything.
Don't play games, you know exactly what I want to know
and you're going to tell me.
What do you want to know?
I will put these on your nipples.
Really?
Yes.
Can you do that?
You like that?
I love it.
That's so weird.
Do that, please.
No, I'm not gonna, no!
We're not doing that.
I want that information!
You are going to tell me.
I can't!
It's a state secret.
I want to know the address of Gal Gadot.
I can't.
I want to visit her and say hello.
You want to kill me?
Kill me.
I won't kill you.
I'll do something worse.
I'm gonna sing Hava Nagila, the way
an Irish man sings Hava Nagila.
No, tell me.
I'm going to do it.
No don't do that.
♫ Hava nagila
Stop!
I'm sorry.
I knew you'd break.
You're a shame to all of Israel.
Now get out of here!